[HAITIAN CREOLE SPEECH]:: Anpil
nan kesyon ke nou te poze nan
kou a te baze sou biyografi
lengwistik etidyan yo.
Li te vreman enteresan ni pou
etidyan yo ni pou mwen menm kòm
anseyan.
SARAH HANSEN: Today on
the podcast, what language
teaches us about identity.
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Can you
be Mauritian but not
speak the Mauritian
Creole language?
Can you be Latino but
not be fluent in Spanish?
Can you be African
American but yet not be
fully fluent in
so-called Black English?
SARAH HANSEN: Welcome
to Chalk Radio,
a podcast about inspired
teaching at MIT.
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
My guest for this
episode created a course
that teaches students
about how language
helps us see and better
understand our world.
Michel DeGraff teaches the
course Creole Languages
and Caribbean Identities.
The course highlights how
linguistics can teach us
about broader issues of
identity, history, education,
and more.
Throughout this
episode, we'll be
intercutting professor
DeGraff's answers
with his Creole translations.
For now, we'll let him
explain more about how he
developed this unique course.
[HAITIAN CREOLE SPEECH]:: Rechèch
mwen se sou devlòpman avèk
MICHEL DEGRAFF: My
research is about
trying to understand how
languages evolve over time
and what happens when new
languages are created.
Say, for example, in the
Caribbean in my native Haiti,
where the Haitian Creole emerged
in the 17th-18th century.
So we try to understand
the patterns of development
of the things that we
call Creole languages.
In terms of the structure, but
also an applied side to my work
where I try to understand
how best to use, say,
Haitian Creole and other
local languages in education.
And how that's crucial
for development
of countries like Haiti.
So the course started
out of a desire
to try to have linguistics
be accessible to a broader
range of students, within which
we could connect languages
to larger issues of
culture and identity.
And as I'm from Haiti and as my
research is Creole languages,
I try to think of
ways in which we
can use the history
of Creole languages
to introduce larger issues
connected to linguistics,
identity, history,
sociology, education.
SARAH HANSEN: Even
though the course
focuses on Caribbean identities
and Creole languages,
the course requires
its students who
come from all over the world
to observe what language
means for their own identities.
[HAITIAN CREOLE SPEECH]:: Se
te [?] moun Anpil yo fèt oz
Etazini
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Can you be
Mauritian but yet not speak
the Mauritian Creole language?
Can you be Latino but
not be fluent in Spanish?
Can you be African
American but yet not be
fully fluent in
so-called Black English?
So those were questions that
they themselves brought in.
Then what I ask them to do as
the very first exercise was
to write what I called
a linguistic biography.
And actually, I got this
hint from a dear friend
and colleague, Professor
Anne Charity Hudley,
and Charity actually
shared with me
her own linguistic biography.
When I read that, I
realized how powerful
it was to read about her
own growing up in terms
of language, ethnicity, race.
So I thought that I would ask
students something similar.
SARAH HANSEN: The connection
between language and power
is highlighted in this course.
A lot of what comes through in
students' language biographies
and other assignments
touches on power structures
and the hierarchies
that exist because
of cultural misconceptions
tied to language and also race.
I asked Professor DeGraff if
students brought misconceptions
about Creole languages
to the course,
and how he unpacked them.
[HAITIAN CREOLE SPEECH]::
Etidyan yo,
yo kòmanse kou a avèk yon se...
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
So one way that we
start by unpacking these
misconceptions is by comparing
attitudes towards
languages with attitudes
towards race and ethnicity.
And what we get to
see very quickly
is that, in fact,
there is perhaps
as much misconceptions
about language
as there is about race.
So they get to see very
early in the course
that language can be
used as a proxy for race,
though now it's impolite to
say certain things about, say,
black people or Asian people.
Yet it's still polite to say
negative things about language.
And then at that
point what we do,
we introduce some basic
linguistic analysis
tools for them to be
able to see that in terms
of basic structure,
there is nothing
at all that is inferior
about Creole languages.
In fact, what we do
from the very beginning
is to show that
structurally there
are patterns both in the
syntax or morphology of Creole
languages that are quite
similar to patterns
in the syntax and history
of English, of French,
of Mandarin Chinese.
So they quickly get a sense that
empirically and theoretically,
one cannot argue that Creole
languages are any way lesser
than non-Creole languages,
the same way that there are no
biological measures that
would deem black people to be
inferior to white people.
So they get very
quick to understand
the power of this myth
that often they themselves
have brought along
in terms of how
they view different languages.
In some cases Creole
language, in other cases
just even dialects of English.
There is Southern
English or Black English.
Their attitudes
are very demeaning
towards those varieties that
have no basis in science that
are rooted in
hierarchies of power,
and they get to see
that very quickly.
This course, the core
of it is discussions.
And in order for the
course to be successful,
we have to be able to discuss
very delicate personal issues
in a very safe way
and to be honest.
It cannot be that students
are afraid to reveal
their positions on various
topics including race,
language, identity.
And one way to do
it is to, given
that I had at the very
beginning of the course--
I had the questionnaires
about where they came from,
what languages they spoke,
where they grew up--
I was able to use that
to trigger discussions.
So if we read a text about
authenticity, for example.
If an African-- can you
be an authentic writer
if you write in
English, for example?
I knew that some of the students
had dealt with this issue.
For example, we
had a student who,
although she was
black and Hispanic,
she wasn't very
fluent in Spanish.
And she wasn't clear whether
her not being fluent in Spanish
made her any less Hispanic.
You see?
So I was able to use that, in
order to trigger a discussion
around this notion that we
had read in this famous debate
between Chinua Achebe and
Ngugi wa Thiong'o about African
writers.
Can a writer be
authentically African
if they write in English,
or French for that matter?
So that was one way to
trigger rich discussion.
So the motive there was
which discussions are best
arrived at if we start
from a personal basis
where students are invested in
trying to find an answer that
can work for them in
their personal lives or in
the life of their families,
their communities,
their countries, et cetera.
SARAH HANSEN: Another
special feature
of Professor DeGraff's
course on OCW
is that his Instructor Insights
are available in both English
and Haitian Creole.
I asked him why it was important
that he share in both languages
how the course was taught.
[HAITIAN CREOLE SPEECH]:: Pou
mwen, se te vreman enpòtan
MICHEL DEGRAFF:
So it was very, I
would say, crucial, for me to do
this interview in both English
and Creole, because I see
Creole languages, even
in the case of Haiti, or
especially because of Haiti,
as a particular revealing
and clear test tube or case
study to really show
how language can
be such a powerful tool,
either for domination
or for resistance.
Either for oppression
or for development.
So I would love teachers
who look at the course
to see how they can adapt
the content in order
to address similar issues
in their own community,
because I think that
what you see happening
in the case of Creole languages
also happens in the US,
happens in Europe, in
Latin America, in Africa--
where language is often used as
this technology for domination
or resistance.
And I think this course gives
some basic analytical tools
to be able to analyze
these patterns.
And for me, it's
also very important
that teachers in Haiti and
students in Haiti including,
say, future leaders
or policy makers,
get to understand the
discourse and the readings
and to understand that
Haiti could do so much
better if teachers,
students, leaders,
had this awareness of how their
own attitudes towards Creole
versus French have played
over centuries in keeping
the country underdeveloped.
And if they could get a
better sense of the importance
of language in education
and development,
then I think the country
would do so much better.
And for me, it's
a key bottleneck
that we have to go
past in order to really
be able to develop a nation--
is to be able to understand
the history and the
nature of your national--
your ancestral language-- and
to be able to use it in a more
systematic and productive way.
If you cannot do that, there's
no way that you can develop
a whole nation that
speaks that language.
What the students
get to understand
at the end of the
course is that we all
hold dear certain
attitudes about language.
And some of these attitudes
are positive for ourselves
and for others, but oftentimes--
and this is actually
one of the major issues that we
discuss throughout the course,
is that sometimes
we have attitudes
that have a negative impact,
severe negative impact,
on the lives of other people.
The lives of, sometimes,
entire communities and nations.
So I hope throughout that
students can actually
take the theory that
is in the course
and see ways in which
they can apply it
to themselves, to
their communities,
to their countries.
So some in the
course of this class
have applied what
they've learned,
and taking it outside, including
volunteering in, say, there
is a dual language program
that's just started in Boston.
It's a joint language
program promoting
the use of both
Creole and English,
and where students are
immersed from kindergarten
in both Creole and English.
And now there's a student
within the class, my class,
who's volunteering in that
classroom for kindergartners
who are learning in
Creole and in English.
And to me, that's a--
it's a dream, because
it's one case where
what you learn in the course
can be directly applied
in the real world context, which
can make actual positive change
in the life of these children.
SARAH HANSEN: Professor DeGraff
shares additional thoughts
on teaching Creole
languages and Caribbean
identities within the
instructor insight
section of his OCW course.
You can find these
dual language videos,
along with his openly
licensed teaching materials,
at ocw.mit.edu.
And if you use these materials
in your own teaching,
we'd love to hear about it.
Use the contact link in the
show notes to share your story.
Until next time, I'm Sarah
Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare.